Joe Biden sounding tone deaf about
America's fentanyl crisis the president
tried to defend himself after a
republican congresswoman wrongly blamed
him for a mother losing her two sons to
the deadly drug that Mom gave
heartbreaking testimony this week and
begged the administration to take action
but instead of Biden being empathetic
the president was more concerned than
the congresswoman got one of her facts
wrong
isn't she amazes
she was very specific recently saying
that a mom a poor mother who lost two
kids to fentanyl that that I killed her
sons the interesting thing is that
fentanyl they took came during the last
Administration anyway I don't want to
get started
keep this in mind Biden gave a half hour
speech and that was the only mention of
fentanyl or the Border The Grieving
mother of those boys not taking his
Carefree comments lightly
oh you know did he just like misspeak
like this shows his heart you don't have
to think about what you say in A Moment
Like This
and to me it's like it shows this is why
he just opened the border so wide he
just doesn't care he's completely
heartless the president owes me an
apology and all of the other parents who
have lost their children they owe us he
owes us an apology the White House
trying to clean up Biden's remarks
the American people knows who he is
fundamentally because he's been around
for some time and they have watched him
go through grief he expressed sympathy
for her last night and his heart goes
out to any person any person who has to
go through that type of trauma his words
are are being mischaracterized
all right Dana the president's brand at
least what they say it is is about
empathy empathy yeah but it's Time After
Time After Time from the border to
fentanyl to East Palestine he's not
shown what his brand is I'm beginning to
believe the whole thing was just phone
um I feel for her the mother in fact
when we saw her at the testimony it's a
it was a very difficult thing to do and
many of these moms who have lost
children to fentanyl poisonings
are the ones who are starting
non-profits in their communities or
figuring out a way to connect with other
moms and basically they have this grief
connection going on all across the
country and it is heartbreaking she is
she lost two of her sons okay
um now at the beginning of the clip when
Biden's talking about uh isn't she
something he's referring to Marjorie
Taylor green so I think that it could be
taken a little bit out of context and
that when he was it seems to be in
mocking her when he was talking about
Marjorie Taylor green but when he talks
about the the mother he is not empathy
empathetic and what I wrote down here is
his empathy instincts are not firing no
and it is true that he has asked for
empathy or leaned on empathy in his own
case right think about Hunter yeah we
talk about it a lot like that any parent
who is dealing with a child who has drug
addiction problems and of trying to
overcome them you have to feel for them
because what they go through is absolute
hell and that's what this woman's gone
through the thing that's surprising
about not even mentioning fentanyl
anywhere else in this speech or
understanding it is that it seems like
another one of these Slow Rolling things
where they're going to all of a sudden
realize that wow they are too slow to
get to it and they're going to look back
and go wow how did we miss it I don't
know how they miss it we're talking
about it all the time it's like the baby
formula problem uh the Border problems
the crime problems because it's covered
here they don't want to talk about it I
don't know why I don't know where Susan
Rice is she's the head of the domestic
policy Council where's the plan is there
any any plan
um what about the cabinet
why can't you just call a cabinet
meeting once in a while that's why
they're there and say I want each of you
to come up with two things that you can
do that Implement to make sure that
we're protecting the children where are
the ads why can't we do any some public
service announcements something like
that that just trying to let kids know
when pill can kill the parents are
asking for help and they are not getting
it at this time we're going to talk a
little bit later about the second
gentleman Kamala Harris's husband he's
looking for a cause this one's staring
him right in the face the one he chose
is
pitiful but we'll talk about that in a
little bit Yeah Greg Gutfeld yeah um
we've been we've been talking about this
well we've been talking about opioids
legally illegally otherwise for years
and I I'm pretty sure it was here I know
I wrote about it I predicted that the
Crackdown on legal opioids would lead to
a mountain of dead because you're not
doing anything about the demand you're
just replacing a safe and legal low-dose
Supply with a street drug of unknown
potency that's often deadly so that's
definitely going to kill more people so
whose fault is that is that it's not Joe
Biden's it's everybody it's Obama it's
Trump it's Biden because we've been
talking about this for years no one was
actually ever engaged on it and it may
be the fox contamination effect or the
five the five contamination effects
anything we talk about because we we
picked aside they can't be on that side
so uh Marjorie Taylor green she they're
both wrong okay she says that Biden
basically has blood on his hands he
doesn't that's probably polygrip but she
learned from the best right where did
you get that vernacular right where did
the where does the new right get the
vernacular from the old left right the
Dems have mastered the blood on your
hands Screech from talking to pro-life
going after pro-lifers to capitalists to
law enforcement to parents fighting you
know to protect their kids from you know
trans activism ideology you can blame
both parties for inaction uh but this
problem's been around for a while and at
least MTG is showing some passion about
it now Joe is wrong right he's using an
example although correct it involves
casualties like when you're in a debate
it doesn't look good to say don't blame
me for those dead kids that's on the
other guy with the mother recently and
freshly there grieving and and it it's
he couldn't resist it he couldn't own in
this case he couldn't own the righty you
know and so he you know he was prepared
for it actually he had this thing so
they're both in the law It ultimately
what this is a tough topic because it's
so weird
does this help stop the flow of illegal
fentanyl that's the question everybody
should asking apparently it gets people
to pay attention when there is this kind
of conflict maybe they'll understand the
topic more and consider ending it maybe
we will go in and we'll bomb these
places on the surface level this feels
like people trying to get at each other
when really they should be cooperating
on killing this enemy
apparently it's not bringing us together
Judge Jeanine
you know I
I I have a bit of a different take
the president of the United States
it's not about Marge retailer green oof
I get that everybody can laugh about
that what it's about is a woman who lost
two sons who feels that she's owed an
apology
we've got an Administration right now
with a guy who's a fool and he's
clueless and I am dead serious about
that there are Americans dying every
year more now than have died in World
Wars and he can't even get the word
fentanyl off his lips and when you need
a press secretary of the United States
to tell the American people that the
president is really everybody knows how
pathetic he is and how empathic he is
we're in a real problem America is
starting to understand the man who hid
in the basement in that Trojan Horse
doesn't care about you if you're from
East Palestine if you're An American in
Afghanistan if you're a mother who lost
two sons who no fault of her own he's
going to say something and laugh about
it and blame it on another guy that is
such the Instinct of the left blame it
on the other guy when his own attorney
general is admitting that fentanyl is an
Unleashed on purpose in the United
States and all we need to do is do
something in Mexico Force the president
of Mexico the way Trump did when he was
trying to get them to control the border
from the illegals he said I'm going to
put tariffs on it and there was some
control right now I'm not interested in
people saying well it could have meant
this or maybe it wasn't empathic enough
that is disgusting what he did showed
the real true heart that he has yeah not
a classy move by the president here
I don't think I would necessarily say it
wasn't a classy move it was obviously
improperly handled that it gave anyone
the impression that he doesn't care
about the fact that a woman lost her
sons to Fentanyl and I would add to what
Dana said he has a son who struggles
with drug addiction and he also has a
son who died of cancer that he talks
about quite regularly someone who you
know served our country died a terrible
death and that's something that he uses
to connect with people and that was
missing from this but
his frustration with Marjorie Taylor
green and the lies that are being told
about his record on this
I think our worthwhile elevating And
discussing so I I was watching something
this weekend that had the moment where
Joe Wilson the congressman from South
Carolina said you lie at Barack Obama
during uh the State of the Union it was
something about Obamacare and it was
like the world was exploding because a
congressman dared do that and uh John
Boehner who was um the leader of the
Republicans made him apologize he called
and apologized and Obama said no problem
you know moving on
and then you look at the last day of the
Union where Marjorie Taylor green is
standing up and howling at him
essentially I mean the pictures from it
and the sounds we all watched it we have
so devolved in the way that we treat one
another that it allows you to
whoa it allows someone like Marjorie
Taylor green to think it's okay to
rampantly lie about someone it does
matter when someone died it matters that
we've had a fentanyl crisis for years
Greg's right about that but saying
because this happened Joe Biden is
guilty of that you should know that it
happened during 2020 when Trump was
president and you can say we have more
deaths now fentanyl deaths than we did
that year but also we have more
apprehensions of fentanyl at the border
by astronomical events astronomical
amounts and that's what this has turned
into there's a new ad out by a liberal
group that's thanking Joe Biden for how
serious he is about the Border because
Marjorie Taylor green stepped in it and
she said 4 800 pounds of fentanyl
confiscated by cpb in 2020 11 200 pounds
in Biden's first year and that's what
you get you just get more partisan
bickering about it because that's what
everyone do what you're saying seizing
more fentanyl than they did last year is
actually a good thing that's like saying
we encountered more illegals at the
border than we did last year well
because it's about apprehensions and
it's about confiscations now I know how
many deaths there are I know that those
numbers continue to go up I'm just
trying to frame the way that partisans
think about this and that's why these
issues that are human issues so rarely
get dealt with because everyone just
goes to their corners and look this is a
mother who lost two sons this is about a
man who's laughing about it and I'm not
talking about the first part of the
statement I'm talking about the second
part he has no empathy she thinks he
needs her that he owes her an apology
then you know what he should give her
that apology I would think that that
would be great I think that that would
be the only way he gets himself out of
this but what I what I can
I'm gonna I'm gonna guarantee I'm gonna
be bold with it that nobody who is a Joe
Biden supporter thinks that he doesn't
care about that mother and everyone who
hates doing this is what you think she
does not think it
I sincerely doubt that that woman all
right well it's voted foreign
we want to see him
in action
just saying you care isn't enough
anymore hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now